plus que demain au non moins que demain
plus qui a pu tain c'est quoi déjà
jean-pierre site waka tâtait monica
bellucci nichant dans le moteur de
recherche
1 ah oui oui oui c'était basse et
c'était pour le travail des rapports
avec une agence immobilière est là on
cherchait un logo et on voulait on
voulait pas que ça ressemble aux niches
au sein de de monica bellucci pour
éviter le éviter le procès emmanuelle
béart q faut il faut être très très
prudent avec les logos
je te quitte philippe beaucoup tu te
fous de tout totalement absents latella
comme une ombre tu t'es jamais impliqué
dans l'éducation des enfants
j'en ai marre moi je peux plus tenir
mais c'est quoi ce qu'il faut mais c'est
dégueulasse de dire que je me suis
jamais impliqué dans l'éducation des
masses julie marque hugo boss ça va je
passe sur les mots
j'ai aussi cet écran plat 75 euros
entièrement fabriqué et assemblé en
chine par des enfants de 9 ans vivent
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires un produit que son
obsolescence programmée entre est peu
fiable sur la durée qu'est ce que t'en
pense et je t'avoue que cette histoire
d'ancien chinois ça me gêne un peu je
vous rassure il travaille avec des gants
donc aucun risque de transmission de
microbes de l'enfant est l'objet mais
l'orgie banco non c'est moins qu'hier
puisque demain voilà